is in as the backup point guard he's
also got George sneezing and Tony
Bradley in off the Utah bench is Jordan
Clarkson missed a three that gets stuck
up in the shot clock
Robo camera apparatus behind the basket
did you call that a robo camera
apparatus is that an official name well
I mean we can we can make it up and we
need to highlight that and we can be
creative shoot from the head on the
floor porzingis is going to be on so
many white ladies dinner and basketball
then he is it Oh Bo buds come on save
the day
[Applause]
Vauban can arrest you they love boom
Kobe he's high-fiving everyone on the
bench yeah
get out of the way seven three guy I've
got this extra credit right earnest
handle things up on the shot clock
oh we're gonna need both on again
where's Bob on JJ is holding off the bow
Oh
Oh porzingis may have a chance to shine
again porzingis can getting back on the
twitter with this
[Applause]
that's so good
this boat just wants to make a
contribution man moena even if it's not
in the game you just